[Musique]
les tueries sont venus faire chanter
l'immigrant les chansons à la gloire
d'un dieu qui croit-il il protège sur le
chemin ne sont plus de 5000 dans ce
stade de mexico
ils avancent ensemble depuis un mois
vers le même les dorades les états unis
allaient tous soignés olavide des radars
des halles reste stable
[Musique]
ils sont fatigués beaucoup sont malades
mais ce soir ils sont heureux ils
dansent car ils reprennent la route
demain se rapprocher du rêve s'éloigner
de la terreur de la pauvreté ils ne le
savent pas encore mais ce soir c'est
peut-être le dernier qu'ils passeront
tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
5h30 les migrants s'engouffre dans le
métro
claudia garcia 18 ans elle s'endort à
côté de francis son amoureux et de leur
porte bonheur une tortue en peluche si
l'accès il a installé waseda
le couple veut s'établir à washington
claudio a vu des images de la villa la
télé et elle a trouvé ça super jeu la
jeune femme est heureuse de voir arriver
ses amis elle était inquiète de ne plus
retrouver 3000 migrants au moins ont
décidé ce matin de rester à mexico et de
demander à l'onu de leur fournir des
autobus
claudia ne possède qu'un petit sac à dos
une couverture rose sa couleur préférée
mais elle traîne en au baguage des
menaces de mort d'une mafia locale pour
une histoire de coeur qui a mal tourné
mais surtout sa mère est très malade
cloud ya vu trouver un emploi pour
pouvoir payer ses soins
dénommé magasins et le salvador il
nécessite avant tout là pour les y est
ce qu'elle est
[Musique]
pedro loi a pris la route avec son bébé
de trois mois sa femme et ses autres
enfants sont restés au pays
il est parti pour pouvoir les nourrir
il n'a pas d'argent demande le monde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pedro claudia et d'autres
vont laisser la parcourir tout ce qu il
m arrivait à carretero plus de 12 heures
après le départ
pedro est épuisé il n'a pas mangé de la
journée son bébé à saint cloud joyent
triste tout le monde manque à l'appel
ils étaient 2000 ce matin ils ne sont
plus que huit cents ans tad où sont les
autres
personne ne le sait encore
5h45 l'immigrant repartent aujourd'hui
ils sont chanceux des camions vont les
embarquer ils appellent ça un web chéri
10 en cours avec sa maman pour ne pas la
manquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous les retrouvons 350 kilomètres plus
loin dans l'aréna de guadalajara
glenda susanna a elle aussi fui des
menaces de mort de bandes criminelles
elle a confié ses deux autres enfants à
sa soeur et elle est partie avec charlie
la seule assez forte pour faire un
voyage
[Musique]
dans l'aréna glenda et sa fille vont
être rejoints dans les heures et les
jours qui suivent ou et par des milliers
d'autres migrants enfants d'autres
parents essentiellement le groupe de
mexico qui s'est résigné à partir car
l'onu leur a refusé l'aide demandée
nous cherchons pedro et son bébé ils
sont introuvables
claudio non plus n'est pas arrivé ici et
elles ne répondent plus à son téléphone
la caravane original c'est donc divisé
en cinq ou six groupes au hasard de la
route
ils se sont promis de s'attendre à la
frontière pour traverser tous ensemble
la dernière fois que nous l'avons vu
claudia nous a dit qu'il était convaincu
qu'elle arriverait aux états unis que tu
l'aiderait dans la mission qu'elle s'est
donnée sous les mails